but now for morning rounds I look at the
medical news of the week we know that
detrimental effects of air pollution can
have on our environment but what about
our health a study out this week from
the New England Journal of Medicine
examined how older Americans are
adversely impacted by air pollution the
authors examine data from 61 million
Medicare beneficiaries from 2000 to 2012
that's more than 96% of Americans aged
65 and older they found in part that
long-term exposure to certain levels of
air pollutants increased the risk of
death joining us from Los Angeles to
discuss the findings is CBS News
contributor dr. David agus doc good
morning good morning
so beyond that headline what are the key
takeaways from this report well the
takeaways from the report are pretty
simple is that ozone and find particular
matter which are from emissions and from
burning hydrocarbons that in the air
they can actually increase the rate of
death in the elderly what's amazing
about this study is they showed that it
was at levels that we consider safe now
even at those levels if we lower them we
would save thousands of lives a year so
it's not as safe as we thought David
when it came to sort of measurable
pollution levels in the u.s. where
certain regions impacted more than
others and and how is that going to
change pollution as pollution strategies
no question about it I mean things like
the fine particulate matters are higher
in the kind of the East Coast dish area
and the ozone on the Left Coast although
cities like Los Angeles are double
whammy hit with both of them and so we
need to be aware of it especially when
there's debate in Washington about
changing these levels what we know now
is that even at the low levels they're
causing problems and potentially
accelerating deaths in some people
doctor this is a problem in the United
States but it's certainly a problem that
is not limited to the United States it's
a global issue how well are we resourced
to research the problem of air pollution
well we ain't there at all this is an
amazing study because of the numbers of
people looked at and they divided the
country into small little areas and
measure the ozone the particulate
matters around the world it's a growing
issue if you go to India and China
sometimes you can't even see across the
street there's so much pollution there
and this is obviously affecting our
health and so we need as a globe to
start to talk about it and figure out
ways to keep it down the the particulate
matters are down dramatically over the
last couple decades but now with the new
debate we're afraid they're gonna start
to rise all right moving on to our next
topic a new initiative in the battle
against cancer according to the Centers
for Disease Control cancer is the second
most common cause of death in the United
States this week former Vice President
Joe Biden and his wife dr. Jill Biden
launched the Biden cancer initiative dr.
agus is on board of the nonprofit he
spoke to the couple after the launch
what I learned from our son's battle was
that and we lost him two years ago not
until seven eight years ago did did we
have this unity of disciplines you have
oncologist and virologist and
biochemical engineers and immunotherapy
and it's all working in a way now that
in my observation didn't work in the
past so David what are the goals of this
second phase of Joe Biden's involvement
with cancer so you know to me it's
inspiring that in tragedy of a family
they're taking that and trying to help
everyone else and help the public and so
the goal of this new initiative is to
accelerate things things that would have
taken ten years they wanted to take five
years and they could do so by removing
hurdles things like access to clinical
trials drug pricing using we call data
standards which is calling everything
the same name so we can pull data and
learn from it he and his wife dr. Biden
and the Vice President are going to work
together with us to try to make a
difference David as Alex eluded to Vice
President Biden was was involved it was
headed up the cancer moonshot where
which is part of the 20th 21st century
cures act bipartisan legislation in the
Obama administration do we need more
legislation like that
well that legislation was certainly
important and put a lot of resources
which is dollars toward fighting of
cancer new dollars that weren't there
before but we need more than dollars we
need to get over some of the regulatory
hurdles some of the aspects we have with
sharing of
and other things and that's what the
vice-president is really going to do in
the war on cancer we need a general and
with the vice president and dr. Biden
all of a sudden we have two generals
helping us that is researchers and
clinicians and patients in the field
achieve progress soon
it sounds like having the vice president
involved in this a figurehead as it were
is has a measurable impact on the
outcome no question about it there are
problems that we've had for a long time
that you know I as a cancer doc and the
researcher we can't overcome but he
knows how to pull the strings he knows
how to talk to the people the different
bureaus of government and bring them
together to make change so it's very
exciting to work on this initiative with
him and with many others across the
country to try to making it back today
to every cancer patient what happens
today maras matters not just tomorrow
finally the limits of the human lifespan
the last century saw great improvements
in our longevity but what's the maximum
age a human being can attain a study
last year in the journal Nature stated
that it was likely around 115 years but
the same journal published commentary
this week from a scientist who refuted
this claim part of one opposing argument
said that there just is no way to know
and predict what the maximum life can
lifespan capacity could be so the
question is will we ever really be able
to know this David it's certainly
interesting this researcher last year
argued that if you look from the 90s
till now the highest age people achieve
was around 115 and so they were arguing
that we were plateauing at that level
but it didn't take into effect that
we're having many new medical
breakthroughs and things are changing so
five new studies are coming out now
showing that potentially we can lift
significant longer 125 or potentially
above with these continued advances so
it's a debate and I certainly hope is
it's the latter that we're gonna live
longer it's a lot of candles on the cake
doc dr. David agus always great to see
you thanks for your time you got it the
fire hazards need a bigger cake